bonjour ses lecteurs l'évêque bienvenue
dans les écuries arrivé il ya tout juste
un mois le cavalier international de
concours complet se sent déjà chez lui à
maisons laffitte
cette yvelinois pure souche a quitté la
boissière école près de rambouillet pour
déménager avec sept de ses chevaux
décision mûrement réfléchie
il y avait un aspect géographique
puisque je suis sur la fin de mes études
à sciences po voilages intègre un master
marketing des sociétés s'étaient
importante pour moi
pour terminer les deux ans qui me reste
de me rapprocher un peu de paris il y
avait aussi la nécessité de voilà me
recentrer un peu plus sur mes chevaux de
compétition j'ai amené que mes jeux faut
vraiment de haut niveau à
maisons-laffitte c'était aussi un choix
personnel
voilà je partage cette passion et ce
sport avec ma copine et puis voilà
c'était je pense important et
intéressant de nous entraîner ensemble
avec cette installation le cavalier de
22 ans espère également trouver un cadre
de vie propice à la pratique de
l'équitation tous les jours victor
l'évêque va s'entraîner dans cette ville
baptisée la cité du cheval en raison de
son importante activité équestre et de
son hippodrome
je crois que ça offre des perspectives
d'entraînement exceptionnel c'est ce que
je recherche aussi avant tout c'est la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir accès aux
pistes avoir accès à la forêt et puis
aussi tous les arts de travail l'écart
de dressage les cards obstacle essentiel
évidemment à la pratique de manspach
haut niveau une ville qui lui permettra
peut-être d'accéder à ses plus grands
rêves avec notamment ligne de mire les
jeux olympiques de 2024
une compétition dans laquelle libinois
espère briller après avoir remporté
quatre titres de champion d'europe chez
les jeunes ce sera je l'espère mes
premiers jeux olympiques
j'ai beaucoup entendu dire que voilà les
jeux olympiques c'est une atmosphère
très différente
on dit souvent qu'il faut aussi mesurer
une première fois avant d'être
performant on verra j'essaierai de
préparer de la meilleure manière
possible
et puis si j'y vais oui je me battrai à
tout prix pour une médaille une médaille
olympique viendrait valider de belle
manière ce choix de déménager à
maisons-laffitte maintenant à place au
travail